all right we're live on the youtube i'm
dave rubin and welcome to another friday
roundtable extravaganza
today we're going to be getting an
update about the never-ending insanity
and endless assault on liberty happening
in the once great country known as
canada our neighbor to the north up
there that's why i pointed out joining
me are political commentator lauren chen
commander of rebel news ezra levant and
a candidate for the people's party of
canada david fryheit aka viva fry
welcome back to the reuben report
everybody
thank you thank you for having us thank
you all right i'm glad to have the three
of you on obviously i've had all of you
on a couple times before so the audience
should be familiar with you guys there
is a lot
of craziness in canada i think that's
probably a major uh underestimate uh so
i want you guys to kind of unpack it
because obviously here in america we
only hear about america we don't really
hear that anything else is happening
anywhere else so uh i'm just first start
off uh with you lauren and if each of
you could kind of answer this if you
could just kind of sum up in like a
minute what do you think the general
state of canada is and then we've got a
bunch of clips we're going to talk about
trudeau and a whole bunch of other stuff
so lauren kick us off
well i think the general state of canada
is unfortunately crisis and i would
disagree that canada hasn't been making
the news even america uh you know we we
had
international headlines when the uh you
know pastors were being arrested when we
had curfews uh when we implemented the
vaccine passport so unfortunately canada
i feel like has been making the rounds
but for nothing good and what's crazy is
that the canadian people themselves seem
to be really polarized about all these
draconian lockdown measures uh you have
some people who are very ardently for it
and i would love to say that all this
craziness is just coming from the top
people like justin trudeau and so many
of the different premieres but
unfortunately a lot of them you know a
lot of the everyday people they do
support this just because we've had a
media whipping people up into a frenzy
yeah i'm actually glad to hear you say
that do you think that there was some
mainstream coverage of this stuff
because you know i don't think it was
really much on cnn certainly not msnbc
but you think it was sort of picked up
in like maybe bbc or independent that
kind of stuff
right and i know tucker carlson
specifically he did do an entire segment
talking about our hotel quarantine
essentially detention centers which are
still going on going on by the way which
the canadian courts have upheld despite
the fact that there are huge human
rights violation there were reports of
sexual assaults going on because you
couldn't lock the doors and things like
that uh so you know for for people who
are interested there are tons of horror
stories on there about what exactly has
been happening in canada but i feel like
if there has been any hesitancy to
report on these things it's because a
lot of the people in the american media
at least they support these measures too
yeah ezra you've been one of the first
guys screaming about all of this stuff
for a long time it's pretty much why you
started rebel news which was one of if
not the first independent news
organization out of canada
what grade would you give canada these
days
it's the worst of times it's never been
this bad
i want to give you an example
justin trudeau announced a 600 million
dollar newspaper bailout that 99 of the
media took that's in addition to his tv
funding so now 99.9
of canadian media are on the dole
literally i mean uh right before the
election he pumped out 61 million
dollars in secret payments
and he refused to reveal which
journalist got the money till after the
election we managed to get an access to
information document
1500 different news outlets
took the cash that's that's got to be
99.9 percent of them so we're at the
stage now where the media in canada is
either owned or rented by the government
or banned by the government and i say
that because for example rebel news
which is which doesn't take any dough
from trudeau we applied to cover the
leaders debates but those have been
nationalized by trudeau so they kept our
reporters out we had to run to federal
court and get an emergency injunction
just to come in the building to ask
questions so i really feel like in
canada you're either a government
journalist paid by trudeau or you're
illegal and i think that applies really
to the people's party and david freiheit
can talk about that they were banned
from this government debate too they're
marginalized they really are narrowing
the bandwidth of what you can say
and do and it's not just you know peer
pressure it's the law
it's government sanctions i really feel
like we are only partly free as a
society we're not a fully free society
anymore we're partly free yeah and look
i hate to say it but i think you guys
are probably just a couple steps further
down that road than we are in the united
states it's probably somewhat comparable
to what's going on in australia uh
that's a good segue david so first off
you're running you're actually getting
involved you know my thoughts on this
it's like we can all talk but we need
people to do
you're a lawyer by training uh you you
do your show with robert barnes on
locals and you guys are crushing it on
there so it's not like you needed this
but you're doing it so first can you
just tell tell the audience that doesn't
know about the people's party why you
joined the people's party and just how's
it going
so yeah it's an amazing thing that i
discovered that there was only one party
in canada that had the slightest
interest in constitutional rights uh
making sure that laws are passed
lawfully even in the time of an
emergency uh that doesn't think vaccine
passports or restricting
inter-provincial travel is justifiable
even in times of an emergency only one
party in canada doing it and i know what
i thought of the people's party of
canada when i read about them in 2018.
because they were demonized back in 2018
i didn't understand any of the dynamics
that i now understand and thanks to ezra
and thanks to rebel about what happens
when the cbc receives a billion dollars
a year from the government what happens
when all the mainstream media receives
hundreds of millions of dollars from the
government
cjd daytime radio here runs covet ads
all day long takes that bailout money
presumably they have become the
cheerleaders for this oppressive regime
they have become quite literally the
purveyors of the propaganda to instill
fear in everybody to the point where you
know healthy middle-aged people who are
double vaccinated have been so beaten
into a state of irrational panic that
they think there's an existential threat
to eat in a restaurant if they don't
know someone else's vaccination status
this is the level of the political
intellectual discourse in canada it's
good to see this there is a bit of an
uprising a bit of an awakening i'm
seeing it as i walk the streets and the
amount of people who secretly say
they're supporting the ppc and or me
it's encouraging but i think we've got a
long way to go to reach the rest who
still think it's a good thing when the
government says we're locking you down
for your safety
yeah and as a guy that just got mugged
by progressive reality here in
california after our recall election
it's like you just got to have hope so
i'm thrilled truly that you got involved
in this thing at a first level uh a
couple of you guys already mentioned
what's going on with some of the vaccine
stuff and some of the money that trudeau
is throwing around basically bribing
government officials at this point but
don't take my word for it here's your
clown prime minister justin trudeau
we will create a one billion dollar
covet 19 proof of vaccination fund
so if your premier wherever you are
across the country
if your premier mandates that everyone
in your local restaurant or gym or other
non-essential locations
must be fully vaccinated and show proof
we'll pay for the development and
rollout of that program
a vaccine mandate for non-essential
businesses
is a good idea
it keeps people safe
it encourages everyone to do the right
thing it keeps our businesses open and
it keeps our economy rebuilding
because keeping you safe
that's my top priority and not just
through this fall
but over the long term too
keeping you safe that's my top priority
i mean my god we are in a dystopian
nightmare
levant he's giving money away to keep us
safe isn't he a great man i mean isn't
that what a good decent man would do
give his own money away he must have a
billion dollars somewhere that he had in
his pocket and now he's going to give it
away to keep you safe ezra why are you
pissed about this
well the money is the least of it it's
the absolute destruction of privacy of
civil liberties the creation of what
rhonda sanderson florida calls a
biomedical security state
and um just a few months ago trudeau was
saying he would never do this it would
create a segregation and a double cl two
classes of citizenship it's a violation
of canada's charter of rights and
freedoms which is like our version of
the u.s bill of rights that
pierre trudeau justin trudeau's own
father brought in but
justin trudeau doesn't care as he said
before he was elected the country he
most admires in the world is china for
its quote basic dictatorship he's a
super fan of castro i mean if a guy
tells you who he is you should believe
him
he's not even the worst though even in
alberta which is sometimes called the
texas of canada
they're actually banning
unvaccinated people from meeting
at home so you heard trudeau say they're
in non-essential places in alberta you
can be perfectly healthy strong as an ox
but if you're not vaccinated you may not
meet other people in your own home so
apparently that's not an essential place
anymore
we are on track for australia in terms
of civil liberties violations and israel
in terms of how many boosters trudeau
has bought 400
million boosters he signed the contract
there's only 38 million canadians he has
bought 10 shots for every man woman and
child
we are locked into this dystopia for
years yeah and if people think you're
making this up i'm pretty sure israel is
already pushing people towards that
fourth shot so it's not as if the idea
of the tenth seems that far away but
come on lauren ezra must be some sort of
right-wing maniac trudeau he's nice he
wears nice socks
i i wish i could say that i had anything
positive uh in my mind about trudeau
right now but i i frankly don't and i
just want to say that as someone who
used to be a drama teacher the level of
insincerity is pretty shocking i would
think that he could at least deliver
those lines better but what's really
concerning is that that billion dollars
that's not the government's money that
that came from canadian taxpayers so if
you are a canadian taxpayer the truth is
you are paying for your own subjugation
and for your own rights to be violated
and that's the case whether you're
vaccinated or not because this is not
about the unvaxxed versus the facts or
anything like that this is about
government overreach which is equally
atrocious whether or not you have taken
the vaccine so that's what really gets
me and that's why me and so many other
canadians were looking at this election
it's like i i don't know how much longer
i can do this i don't know how much
longer i can pay these absorbent taxes
uh that i know are going to programs
that are designed specifically to
exclude me from public life it just
makes my stomach churn okay you know you
mentioned the inauthenticity of trudeau
and it very much reminds me of what we
just dealt with or what we i guess we're
going to still deal with now for a
couple years in california which is
gavin newsom that that he reeks of
inauthenticity and just it's dripping
off these people and i'm wondering david
i'll throw this to you like do people
like when you talk to a trudeau
supporter if they'll talk to you do they
think he's a good guy i mean do they
think he's genuine do they think he
really wants to save them and somehow
you and maxime and the rest of the
people's party of canada people are are
mean and scary and want them to be
diseased
this is where i find some encouragement
i and i'm not saying this to be
hyperbolic i have not met one person
even as i went door-to-door in my
district who likes or says they support
trudeau you have those who say they're
going to reflexively vote liberal just
because
but everybody i've spoken to loathes him
and is looking for somewhere else to
vote now a lot of them are going to go
to the new democratic party uh but a lot
of them are saying anything but trudeau
even the die-hard liberals they say i've
been liberal my whole life i'm not
voting liberal now so i just need to
find the alternative and it's up to me
to convince them to
vote ndp out of protest or vote uh ppc
out of protest and principle but another
thing about that billion dollars that
blows my mind and enrages me it's not
just our taxpayer dollars our healthcare
system is the reason why people are
being locked down they say we're
overloading it it can't deal with this
we're understaffed so what does trudeau
do spends a bill or promises a billion
dollars on an app instead of just
investing that into the healthcare
system alberta's now
says that they're overloaded because
they have 310 icu beds in a province of
4.5 million
they're squandering money on useless
things like covet ads and apps instead
of investing into the system while
implementing a vaccine passport system
that is necessarily and knowingly going
to chase unvaccinated healthcare workers
out of the system which is already
understaffed so it is either
incompetence malice or a combination of
the both but it's the worst possible
situation politically and i think even
liberals can accept that at this point
all right well look clearly i've brought
on three very far right
crazy people because it couldn't
possibly be that justin trudeau would
also be assaulting free speech i mean
we've talked a little bit about covet
but i'm going to throw this video here
and it can't possibly be that this guy
justin trudeau would also be assaulting
canadians right to speak freely
video people need to be safe people need
to feel safe in canada and over the past
years
unfortunately we've seen a rise
in intolerance and acts of hatred not
just in a political context
but across the country
that is why
we need to continue to be unequivocal
about standing up against hatred and
discrimination as we have as a
government as we need to continue to
there's not a debate around vaccines
there's not a debate around climate
change we know for the safety of
canadians and future generations
we need to step up
it is unacceptable there continue to be
acts of racism and intolerance in
communities across the country whether
it's political or not
we need to do more which is why we're
going to be moving forward on stronger
controls over online hate and harms
while respecting freedom of speech but
you don't have the freedom to hate you
don't have the freedom to incite to
violence and our government that has
taken many steps on this will continue
to because no one should feel unsafe
particularly not someone who's coming
out to volunteer and support uh in a
political campaign to make this country
even better
i think i have blood dripping out of my
ear after listening to that
there's so much there so first off
there's no debate on vaccines we can't
have a debate on vaccines can't have
debate on climate change either he sort
of slid that one in there uh there's uh
you can't have hate can't have hate but
it's not an assault on free speech i
mean that's a complete oxymoron
and then the last line which i thought
was particularly interesting no one
should feel unsafe particularly not
someone who's coming out to volunteer
and supporting a political campaign to
make this country even better
guys you may remember this video i'm
springing this one on you i was in
canada two years ago speaking with
maxine bernier and a few other people
and it was a political event and this is
what happened
[Music]
me
one should uh
fear
uh you know coming out to volunteer at a
political event uh there was tons of
violence there by the way that elderly
woman i know you guys have seen this
video her husband fought actual nazis in
world war ii
trudeau didn't manage to say anything
about that what could be going on here
ezra
yesterday there was an arrest in calgary
alberta of a man who was
charged with vandalizing churches over
the last two months more than 50
churches in canada have been burnt
or vandalized or attacked in some way
justin trudeau has not called it a
terrorist attack not called it a hate
crime in fact trudeau's right-hand man
gerald butts calls it
understandable so there's certain kinds
of hates hatreds and hate crimes that
trudeau is fine with
it's funny how he just sort of mushes
things together
he talked about inciting violence i'm
obviously against that but in the same
bucket he put having a different opinion
on vaccines having a different opinion
on global warming he he also threw in
racism implying that if you're
vaccine hesitant you're racist he
occasionally calls people misogynist for
the same thing
even though his own pollster says the
typical vaccine hesitant canadian is a
42 year old mother who votes liberal so
he just is actually the intolerant one
who can't stand other points of view
i
i tell you that he has actually put
forward his draft legislation to crack
down on the internet should he be
re-elected and what scares me dave
is that although trudeau has this huge
plan to regulate the internet
the conservative party which you would
expect to be against at the party of
aaron o'toole has not said one word
against the online harms proposal
in fact the party spokesman on the issue
believes that youtube and other online
sites should be regulated for hurtful
and harmful speech i'm not talking about
crimes i'm talking about hurt feelings
it's coming under the liberals or the
tories dave lauren you talk about this a
lot on your show and we've talked about
it a bunch sort of this like elite where
it makes no difference whether they call
themselves liberal or conservative at
least from a um from a canadian
perspective they're just sort of all in
on it together so the conservatives
aren't going to do anything about you
know defending your right to speak or
anything like that
no it's very terrifying that in canada
at least the conservative party has also
refused to condemn vaccine passports and
so as someone who openly supports the
ppc i have for a while now one of their
founding members uh you know that there
are a lot of us out there that's just
like a special thing you got when you're
signed up on the website not to make
myself seem more important than i am
but there are a lot of us uh who have
been called uh you know vote splitters
and oh essentially a vote for maxim
bernier is just a vote for justin
trudeau well no let me tell you what a
vote for justin trudeau looks like it's
voting for aaron o'toole i don't support
justin trudeau because i i don't support
these coveted restrictions i don't
support you know hate speech legislation
i don't support mass migration all these
things aaron o'toole is also in favor of
so if i if i don't want it from justin
trudeau then i'm sorry i don't want it
from aaron o'toole either and that's why
the ppc has been such a brushed breath
of fresh air there we go for me and so
many other canadians who for the longest
time have felt politically unrepresented
by the mainstream parties and by the way
you know just for justin trudeau to know
uh inciting violence is already illegal
in canada there's already laws on the
books for that so we don't need any more
if that really was what he was concerned
about and it's very it's honestly
sickening that he would even think to
throw in actual uh calls to violence
with just mean words that hurt people's
feelings as if those two things are in
any way comparable
david i
suspect i know the answer to this
question but what are some of the things
that the media is saying about you you
know as you know i talked about i'm here
in cali and watching what the media did
to larry elder was just extraordinary
and then when gavin newsom had his
acceptance speech he said it was a win
for diversity i mean these people it's
the height of hypocrisy there's just not
really there's no ending to line but i'm
wondering how how's the mainstream media
treating you guys because when i did
that event with maxine and actually i
think lauren i think that's when i met
you for the first time actually in
person you were yeah
yeah um when i did that event there were
christians and jews and muslims there
were gays and straights and blacks and
browns and asians and nobody cared and
all anyone talked about was freedom and
everything else but i suspect that's not
exactly how they're talking about you
guys
uh well i'll say i've been fortunate on
an individual basis because i think i
have enough of a social media footprint
that throwing out those types of
accusations wouldn't stick against me
the party itself it's the standardisms
you know anti-immigrant anti-science
anti-vaxxer when i went door-to-door
that's what the individuals who thought
poorly of us thought uh
by and large because that's what the
media just repeats over and over again
because like i told uh rebel news in an
interview what they do is ignore and
demonize so they don't give the ppc a
platform then they misrepresent them in
their absence uh but i think that's
changing and if that's you know one of
the influences that i've had i would be
very happy to have had that effect but
the one thing that blows me away in all
of this uh dave is when justin trudeau
was talking about racism and intolerance
i tweeted the stats that ezra was
referring to out to trudeau a little
while ago with a nice montage of him
literally saying one thing six months
ago and the exact opposite six months
later we're not a country that makes
vaccinations mandatory six months later
i believe vaccinations
i said you are putting into effect a
policy that will have a disparate impact
on racial ethnic religious minorities i
showed the stats latinos blacks are less
likely to get vaccinated or more likely
to be vaccine hesitant uh the indigenous
population just over 50 percent
vaccinated compared to 79
of the the gen population at large and
then lo and behold at our first uh
candidates debate in west mount uh all
the candidates are on stage and there
was a woman from the christian heritage
party who happens to be a black woman
and i hate tokenizing people but it's a
relevant detail black woman from the
christian heritage party not vaccinated
apparently the only one on stage not
vaccinated was such an existential
threat to everyone in that room who was
double vaccinated she was escorted off
stage by security uh and her seat was
left uh not empty because uh the other
two candidates took that spot escorted
off stage so for a prime minister who
rants and raves against racism that he
thinks exists he is the only one
actively promoting it and knowingly so
yeah well if it makes you guys feel any
better from an american perspective we
have plenty of video of joe biden and
kamala harris and pretty much everyone
on msnbc and cnn saying that they were
against mandates and they're for them
now so this is a worldwide uh that's a
real pandemic a pandemic of of lying
lauren do you sometimes think that some
of this is by design that they purposely
they're just punking all of us at all
times that they don't believe in
anything other than power so it's like
yeah we used to be against mandates now
we're for mandates
like literally everything they flip and
lie about everything i can't find one
point that they don't do this on at this
point
i don't really have any other answer
aside from that this must all be some
part of an agenda because it's
definitely not about the science it's
not actually about saving lives i mean
if it were about the science i know in
quebec right now it's you cannot
do outdoor dining unless you are
vaccinated and i've walked through uh
malls and even outside of malls there
will be like little benches and there'll
be signs saying you cannot stop to eat
here unless you have a vaccine passport
makes no sense at all uh where i live
you can't have you know you can't play
devil's tennis without being vaccinated
and things like this if it were about
the science i think things would be
looking a lot different uh what i don't
understand though is how could these
leaders have such clear contempt for the
freedoms of canadians where they feel
comfortable doing that and i that i
don't have a clear answer for because
there are a lot of people you know ford
as well you know the albertan premier
who previously i thought fairly high of
and they had made a lot of promises
about wanting to safeguard canadian
freedoms but it seems like you know
every canadian politician that you would
have assumed would stand up for our
rights has eventually fallen and really
there is just you know on the national
stage only maxine bernier it seems who
is fighting for our right to medical
freedom yeah and there was that
incredible moment maybe one of you guys
can clean it up for me if i slightly
butcher it where he was was he being
arrested or pulled over and they and he
said why and he it was something to the
effect david i'm sure you can clean it
up for me but in essence
the only thing you're afraid of uh from
me is my words i mean it's a really
beautiful beautiful moment can you can
you please fantastic
uh well i i it was fantastic and ezra
and rebel covered it and covered it
thoroughly uh i believe where he said
where he's getting arrested and he says
do you have any weapons on what was he
getting arrested for
he was getting arrested i believe it was
in june for holding an outdoor political
rally in alberta in defiance of public
health measures where literally three
days later in ontario they were holding
a thousands plus person vigil for the
victims of that horrible attack on a
muslim family
three days later you have thousands of
people gathering in ontario with
politicians speaking at the event
uh he was arrested maxime for holding a
park rally outdoors of a few dozen
people and as he was being arrested the
police officer says do you have any
weapons on you and he says weapons no
only my words yeah and he was arrested
detained for i think it was only the day
and release but the political double
standard of the science uh can cause
anyone with half a brain to question
whether or not in fact to deny to doubt
that this is in fact about the science
this is about
political control political censorship
and using it as an excuse to control
every aspect of citizens private and
public lives yeah it's a really
beautiful moment i'll retweet it after
this so that people can see it if they
haven't seen it already and and by the
way i should note that um i wanted
because i'm sure people are watching
wondering where maxime is uh he's on a
plane right now so we couldn't get him
on now the election is tuesday is that
correct
monday
the election's monday so i can't
unfortunately i'm heading on a plane
right after this i unfortunately can't
have him on before uh but what i mean
are you guys hopeful this will be the
wrap-up question but are you guys
hopeful despite all of this i mean
you're all still living there i'm still
living in cali i'm you know my hope
thing is
pretty much exhausted um but how do you
guys feel just on a personal note
fighting for these things that seem to
be slipping away ezra
oh i'm as pessimistic as possible the
people's party and maxine bernier will
do well but
in canada's system you can come in
second or third everywhere but not get a
single representative in our parliament
i think that's going to happen what we
have here is worse than what you have in
the states dave because we have a total
failure of the entire system
every government is for the lockdown
there's no ron desantis but also every
opposition leader is for the lockdown so
you have no distinction between the
government and the opposition the
mainstream media is completely on side
academia pop culture the law professors
the courts the police at least in the
united states you have pockets of
resistance and your supreme court has
thrown out the worst of it in canada
every single knot in the net has broken
at the same time there is not a single
establishment force that is
countervailing this enormous civil
liberties defeat where the civil
liberties groups in canada they're
utterly silent so while there are little
green shoots of hope in america i mean
for example we all see those enormous
college football stadiums cheering in
certain parts of america lives back to
normal it's not back to normal anywhere
in canada and it's getting worse and
actually just yesterday in court uh
they're trying to put that christian
pastor arthur pavlovsky back in prison
for 21 days not making this up because
he won't apologize to the government
dave these are the worst of times it's
not the best of times and the worst of
times
it is the worst of times
canada
is
in distress
and americans should watch because god
forbid you're next
yeah i mean it's evil running everywhere
and everyone that watches my show knows
i always try to spin things positively
otherwise how could i do what i do and
and why would people watch these shows
to endlessly be depressed and yet here
we are lauren i mean this is going to be
on the personal side but you you just
publicly announced you're you're
pregnant which we're thrilled about
obviously and congratulations to you
yeah but as someone bringing a child
into the world right now i mean you must
be
no i don't mean the public person lauren
chen but the the private person lauren
chad like just worried about the future
that you're bringing this child into i
am very worried and frankly i mean i was
born in canada but i grew up in asia i
studied in the us so the prospect of
moving if things get really bad that's
not something that's foreign to me the
same cannot be said of my husband he's
someone who's you know born and raised
his family has been in canada
specifically the same part of canada for
generations and generations and
unfortunately it's really taken this
whole pandemic quote unquote to open his
eyes to the fact that look unless things
change really fast for the better our
child will not be able to grow up with
the same freedoms that we had if we
continue to live here and it's
terrifying i'm going through you know
all my pregnancy appointments by myself
right now because my husband is not
allowed with me because of cobit
restrictions i'm having to wait five
weeks for a blood test uh it's just this
is
i
you said this is personal and i i feel
like that's how the government has made
it like they are personally very boldly
discriminating against me making my life
harder so i feel like canada has frankly
left us behind wait what could possibly
be the rationalization for not allowing
your husband who you're obviously
spending every day with and sleeping in
a bed with to come to your appointment
i'm not sure but i know i had my first
sonogram not that long ago posted the
you know the photo on twitter and i was
told explicitly he could not come um so
that was a very emotionally hard thing
to do to you know see the
your child's beating heart for the first
time by yourself and it's even making me
emotional thinking about it um that's
not something i'll be able to get back
david since you got in you you got in
you said i'm not just going to talk
about it i'm going to fight for it i'm
going to give you the last word here as
a
blossoming politician i mean where's the
hope part or if you believe that there
is
i'll i'll put a little bit of white
veneer on ezra and lauren's black pill
because i think there is some hope let
me just get my rage out uh when i hear
the 13 year old kids are being denied uh
sports tryouts after school because they
don't have the vaccine passport it
enrages me to the point of tears i got
an email from someone uh the other day
saying her husband passed away and for
the last eight days of his life she
couldn't be with him in the hospital
because of covid
these are these are uh traumas that uh
will leave scars and i they're difficult
uh to forgive for
with that said i've been walking the
streets i've been talking to people
there seem to be a lot of people who are
getting fed up even those who are on
board up until the vaccine passports
we'll see what the election results are
i'm predicting there may be a lot of
close second and third finishes but the
ppc are gonna get i'm predicting half a
dozen to maybe if we're lucky ten seats
across the country so that there will in
fact be meaningful opposition in
parliament because it's true what ezra
says there is no opposition right now
conservatives block ndp they are all on
the same page for all the most draconian
measures and don't expect any of them to
change the rules if or when they ever
get into power because they're going to
realize that they benefit from
tremendous power
so the ultimate uh litmus test or what
is it called referendum will be the
election if it's a disastrous result
then i may be a little more uh less
white pilled or less optimistic if we
get six to ten seats in of a voice of
reason a real opposition i will have a
little more optimism all right a little
a little white pill to go with a lot of
black pill well you guys uh
the three you were awesome and just
fighting a very difficult thing i'll
keep fighting with you as long as you'll
fight with me and i thank you guys i'm
going to continue without you
but especially david to you good luck on
monday and uh i'll talk to you guys soon
canada
canada canada
it's like this is happening in canada
nobody thought this could happen in
canada this is happening in australia
australia
we had an
abject disaster happen here in
california this week for freedom if you
care about freedom
uh it's happening across the west and
from my estimation at this point if you
think that the biggest virus that we
have to fight right now is covid in that
it gets people sick and has a 99
recovery rate uh there's a much bigger
virus that i'm worried about and it's
the mind virus that is now proliferating
everywhere and
allowing once decent people to be very
confused about simple things that we
used to know to be true
and to
literally hand over their rights here
are my rights
here are the documents you wrote them on
you take them you take them i'll figure
it out as i'm locked in my basement with
the mask on getting my 17th booster shot
what are we doing to ourselves what what
are we doing what are we doing
um but because you know i like to give
you a little a white pill when we when
we do something like this and this was
obviously you know sort of a rough week
for me personally but as i said over the
last couple days you know i'm very proud
about fighting for california and
fighting for larry and i'll
make all the decisions trust me all the
conversations that you think i'm having
with with david and my team and
everything else they're all they're all
being had um but i'm very proud about
fighting for california and giving it
everything i got and more importantly
fighting for larry elder who is a damn
decent man who did not deserve to be
treated the way he was which i have no
doubt is exactly what david and the
people's party uh candidates are dealing
with up in canada right now um actually
we had larry and his girlfriend over for
dinner last night and we just had a
great night just letting off
some steam just you know just being
friends and not even talking politics
the whole time and i assure you that
larry's got big plans like don't think
this is the end of larry i don't think
this is the end of all the things we've
been fighting for and everything else um
but our work is cut out for us it really
is as simple as that so
that's kind of where we're at uh guys
next week i'm actually leaving for new
york tonight i'll be gone for the week
um we do have an interview with jason
whitlock from the blaze who's awesome
it's it's a very i we taped it yesterday
we're gonna put it up next week it's
really really interesting a little bit
of a different take it's not purely
political it's a lot about sports and of
course sports has melded into politics
so will that we'll put that up next week
i'll be live in studio with greg gutfeld
on gutfeld exclamation point on fox news
on wednesday night and i may do a couple
other media hits while i'm in new york
and maybe i'll do some walk and talk so
we'll get something up on youtube for
you guys but everybody keep fighting
look and i you know i got a ton of
messages of messages this week about
people being depressed and people are
planning to move and i you know i see
what everyone's saying mostly where i
check things of course is the locals
community and everyone's kind of just
whacked out this week but from that
it's like then we gotta piece something
together right that's why i always talk
about building like
trudeau ain't gonna be the guy that
saves them in canada and joe biden ain't
gonna be the guy that saves us here
we're the ones that can save ourselves
and uh oh and one other thing i wanted
to mention um you know yesterday was was
the holiest day in the in the jewish
year it was yom kippur
which is the day of atonement and i went
to services that are led by dennis
prager now dennis prager is not a rabbi
he doesn't have like a regular
congregation
but he does do these services uh for the
high holy days and i i went a week ago
for rosh hashanah i went to yom kippur
he gave a sermon yesterday and he makes
a point of not talking about politics
you know most of the people that come
it's about 400 people it was jam-packed
standing room only most of the people
that come listen to his radio show or
prageru videos or whatever it might be
so they're they're fans of dennis so
it's an interesting somewhat
self-selected audience um and dennis
makes a point of not talking about
politics from the pulpit he brings it up
repeatedly that even though they love
him for that and those ideas that's not
what he's there to do and he has a
really wonderful way of talking about
religious ideas and the importance of
them and all those things but he gave
his sermon yesterday and it was um
it wasn't political
but it was political because
everything's political right now because
freedom is on the ropes and to talk
about freedom as he discussed yesterday
to talk about freedom is to talk about
belief
is to talk about the ideas that you know
our ancestors fought for so we could
live in free societies that maybe are at
the end of their freedom so it was quite
moving to me and and the other reason i
bring it up is that one of the things
that dennis talked about is that you
know during yom kippur you're supposed
to you're supposed to repent for your
sins if you've wronged somebody you
should apologize to them that sort of
thing and he was talking a lot about
lying and that once you put lies out in
the world
that you can't put them back you know
what i mean a lie is just a wave of
water and you can't get that thing back
in the cup and there are lies everywhere
like what a week of lies
everything you heard justin trudeau just
say right there everything that joe
biden and barack obama and gavin newsom
said about larry elder everything that
they say on mainstream media about all
of us it's just like a lie factory
everywhere and
so where's the white pill part of that
it's on us to correct the stuff
that i have nothing better to do so
let's do it together right like that's
it uh all right if you want to see all
the adventures and behind the scenes
things that i'll be doing in new york
join me at reubenreport.locals.com the
community's exploding by the way and i'm
i'm thrilled to just be part of that
with you guys and just meet so many of
you as i met at the larry elder election
night party and everything else so uh
join us over there that's it have a good
weekend and uh well i'll see you next
week one way or another somehow you know
because internet i can't really see it
anyway it's an odd thing that television
people always say but here we are okay
goodbye